okay [ __ ] okay snatches it's your boy
uh what path of oxide I was psych eval
oh and them you know it just made
chillin here we're about to play some
last of us lasting Herbie jumped in a
[ __ ] skull okay we did we're hiding
we're hiding like little [ __ ] in a
school um anyway I smell like [ __ ] I
haven't showered in like five days and I
spilled some meat on my arm and [ __ ]
smells it's been like two days I still
smell like [ __ ] pork I love work that
was up not complaining i complaining
uh-huh okay here we go oh uh huh where's
that [ __ ] over there ah you were gonna
play it this way huh come on i watch it
around [ __ ] Oh
I'm pressing a square Oh God God oh you
like this [ __ ] I'm gonna share feel
like I ship that woman next time that's
I melee weapon oh [ __ ] Oh [ __ ] [ __ ] you
up oh [ __ ] mommy daddy will you cut the
girls classrooms ok let me hell out I'm
help for daddy Sam get us now [ __ ] I
don't have a weapon how did that happen
what is this sound I broken chef oh [ __ ]
well just goes to show what happened to
any try and go come and I'll you know oh
thank you and I'll take this what is
this I'm full of bricks it's house I've
got too many works ok yeah it's like
that's that ya thank ya can I make get I
made why this that's [ __ ] oh [ __ ] i
don't have a melee weapon it's gonna
[ __ ] down with all right um yes yes
mar chef or ships ok that's a what is
this is this for me yes that is baby
shut the [ __ ] out [ __ ] I am the master
of my fav I am the captain of my soul
this way
why do I feel [ __ ] clicking who I
will be taken at that oh [ __ ] i'm
pressing square oh they stop turn they
stopped here on a [ __ ] face wow it is
so much easier just to fight your way
through this game take test ok I'm full
of model shows us I'm full a bottle
chasez ok they then get here hey is that
into the bottle too loudly oh shet Oh
looks like there's a path down this
world
oh man okay yeah yeah for this thank you
hi this may just do a little silent
check okay help me open this help me
help a nice batch yes I read a lot of
[ __ ] noise on the way barricade the
doors start kick it justly gonna hold up
for long
good what the [ __ ] is that oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] and [ __ ] now what the [ __ ] was that
okay okay outside I guess you like this
[ __ ] you're gonna suck some dick
tonight gonna suck C deck tonight
you
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] where is that [ __ ] oh oh
oh it looks like i had stomach pains I'm
sorry yeah now let's not for a long time
we call them bloaters glad I hate to
interrupt your little biology lesson but
can we get the [ __ ] out of here please
yes yes I would like that what is that
let's get the [ __ ] out of here I hate to
interrupt your biology lesson but let's
just go okay let's just go and I says
I'll take this hmm [ __ ] we more these
bad boys okay I hate to burst your
bubble because that any as many of these
as we can I get you need some brew
shelves Jesus oh wait can I come on
what's up maximum health I'm good
oh thank you take that's like ya thank
ya thank ya I can't make any of that
sign I guess I'll shut we can't leave
here that cares yeah we gotta go up
there so let's come here let's go people
that I'm the booster oh hell yeah
actually a little fighter I got on that
all right come on a fighter Joe behind
you shut shut oh you like you like fight
you people huh you like that kind of
thing you want a fight [ __ ] you own a
fight I'll teach you how to fight [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] I'm dad you [ __ ] hate
those things you're [ __ ] [ __ ] Oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] just standing there
doing nothing just standing there and
doing nothing jay says all right product
let's go come on thanks thanks for
letting up now thank you
before what a bent to too much energy to
get up you know come on come on come on
come on come on [ __ ] [ __ ] stuff no
side the house yeah sure Jessica so that
worked out well no didn't le [ __ ]
stupid ah disaster I'll go check out
this side of the house yeah jay says
well if somebody had the same idea they
stole my [ __ ] well then what the hell is
playing be you ought to be thankful
you're still drawing breath that was
playing ABC all the way to [ __ ] Z and
furthermore tell test she could take oh
shoot a high tension as you have it
right nothing to do Janice s hoja nice
guy or some Frank who the hell's Frank
he was my partner oh [ __ ] he's the only
idiot that would wear a shirt like that
ok
he's got bites hear me sad I reckon he
didn't want to turn yeah I guess not
well [ __ ] him look what I found it's got
some juice in it that's my battery
uh-huh [ __ ] hassle get out get out
look jeez [ __ ] zech batteries drain
but cells are alive meaning meaning we
push it get it started y'all later or
recharge the battery is that your guests
look you wanted a plan be as good as it
gets that's true that's true beggars
can't be choosey I don't know what you
think of this place sucks alright and
you drive and we push that's more of my
stuff hey stylish a [ __ ] get over it oh
yeah wait I should check just gonna
steal my [ __ ] the runoff is that it
Frank very loud you should probably
search the house sure there's more
supplies that's good idea there's a damn
good idea okay what are we a hell of a
lot Jessica okay okay
I'll give you a holler [ __ ] filthy
Frank but is this is cracked in this is
a cracked em cuz I'll have no part of a
crack then okay oh so make sure this is
full and take this I'll take tests i
gotta count no Frank oh my god
holy [ __ ] that was really [ __ ] up
better not shown that one yeah okay let
me just check to see if I could make
anything I want more help okay it's
[ __ ] all on through it okay ever get
forget already yeah yeah they're lie
final mix in there now yeah I figured
you should have it why would you ever
give the same [ __ ] you do Frank [ __ ]
idiot you ready to go that Garrett some
again let me so funny you will be ok
with this yeah not a problem you're
doing a good job your are gotta move it
give her God won't let you down with
this even dry with on the streets like
filled what let's do it ok we're in
first how he did it keep your foot on
the clutch and when we get to where I
know how to Poppa clutch how the hell
did you are no care just don't [ __ ] it
up ok get ready hit it hit it oh [ __ ]
don't work hey good job kid bill not
helping le we're gonna give it another
go stay focused
are they out here yeah you [ __ ] [ __ ]
suck my dick you [ __ ]
Oh [ __ ] [ __ ] oh you like that you're
going down hell we're gonna add alluring
pushing [ __ ]
how I can't rely much time back to
pushing come on come on reload okay
let's go let's go
oh [ __ ] sky over there
okay I'm relighting I bailout it's got
burned out of get ready I like this
music now alright Haley starting up
that's a noble let's do this [ __ ]
let's do this yeah [ __ ] this is from
the clock i know
yeah how's intense alright guys thank
you hun kicks out for her Amish